at nemo's chip shop on belfast lisbon
road the writing is literally on the
wall what's your glove
the spiraling cost of fish and oil
largely due to the war in ukraine has
left the owners in an impossible
situation
so what is someone willing to pay for a
piece of code and some chips that are
willing to pay 20 pounds are they
willing to pay 30 pounds because it's a
i think it's a 15 at the minute but
we're not going to go to 20 or 30 or 40
pounds it's just
amazing shut the shop he doesn't say
that lightly the family have already
shot one of their four chippers due to
soaring energy costs and those look set
to increase again northern ireland's
utility regulator has warned gas prices
will increase by 30 percent from october
and with no devolved government in place
the delivery of the 400 pound energy
payment has been delayed
started in march we weren't brought in
discussions until late till uh june
early july and you know that has brought
the some of the delays to the process
and getting them 400 pounds out to
consumers here which must be frustrating
for you and your office as well
absolutely frustrating because
customers need it you know this is the
most vulnerable area in the whole of the
uk and
customers need support coming into this
winter period
all of this means that people are
turning to community supports here in
north belfast the ashton center has
opened a pop-up school uniform shop
where hundreds of parents have been
given uniforms that can cost up to 500
pounds for free families are very very
emotional whenever they come in and they
have very very little and they're
walking away with everything from a full
uniform to the children's horror
accessories to new socks
it's wonderful to be able to do this
this work the centre has also opened a
store where for five pounds families
receive 40 pounds worth of groceries
one of the things that really i thought
oh my goodness where are we as a society
this gentleman said can i take a
toothbrush she said i don't have a
toothbrush now what sort of society we
living live in another toothbrush is
considered a luxury
it's a perfect storm of vulnerability
disposable income in northern ireland
was already less than half of the
nationwide average and in a time of
crisis there's no government to look to
for strong leadership just a political
vacuum and the rocketing cost of even
life's simple pleasures
stephen murphy sky news in belfast